over the weekend President Trump visited
fire ravaged California accompanied by
Democratic Governor Jerry Brown and
governor elect Gavin Newsom the
president was clearly moved by the
extent of the devastation nobody would
have ever thought this could have
happened so the federal government is
behind you were all behind each other I
think they can truly say Jerry and Jerry
and I have been speaking in Gavin and I
have now gotten to know each other and
we're all going to work together and
we'll we'll do a real job this is very
sad to see as far as the lives are
concerned nobody knows quite yet
they'll up to a certain number but we
have a lot of people that aren't
accounted for I think we're all in the
same path what was unexpected was how
Governor Brown and governor luck Newsom
responded to their day with the
President and of course his personal
interest in the tragedy like politics
being played here the expectation going
forward that the federal government is
not just gonna be here today with all of
you but tomorrow and over the course of
the next few years as we rebuild
well sure the cynics are gonna say this
is all just a show because Brown and
Newsom they know they're gonna need the
federal government's help to recover
from the worst fires in the state's
history but still it was nice to see in
the last few weeks notwithstanding some
ill-advised tweets about Adams shifts
name and retired Navy Admiral William
McRaven President Trump seems to be
projecting a different dimension of
himself understanding now that he has a
Democrat house and he has to contend
with that might President Trump be
trying a new approach to governance
should he would this change minds or
gross support for his economic agenda
it's clearly working but beyond all of
that wouldn't it be good for the country
I get the sense maybe you do too that
Americans have undoubtedly grown weary
of how politics has infected so much of
our daily
lives not that it's not important it
obviously is where I wouldn't be doing
this every night but it's not everything
and it shouldn't be a bloodsport every
single day the president doesn't need to
swing at every pitch nor does he need to
respond to every unfair criticism no
matter how vile it is not even when it
comes from self-absorbed media figures
now this Thursday is supposed to be a
time when we all gather around the table
to give thanks not to get stuffing
thrown at us by cousin Helen or Uncle
Joe who's you know in a white rage about
the president's views on climate change
or something maybe just maybe the
president has decided to modestly
recalibrate his approach to his job and
find places where both parties can agree
even as the critics persist now believe
me I'm not saying he should change his
goals on core issues like trade or
immigration he's doing great on both but
he could be changing how he pursues them
I think the president needs more happy
not more anxious voters going into 2020
a recent morning consult poll showed
that 64% of voters believe the media
have divided the country while 56% not
an insignificant number blame the
president now it's not surprising that
nearly two-thirds of Americans blame the
press given how biased and how
completely unbalanced most of them are
and they've been toward this president
since the beginning President Trump is
ratcheting up his anti-immigration
rhetoric using the White House podium to
stoke fear look I I don't I don't I
don't know what the president's
anti-semite or not I get asked that
question a lot I think we all do I also
know that he has said things that are
heard as dog whistles by anti-semites he
goes on television and pronounces
himself a nationalist nationalist that
word has been used in many ways it was
used by the American Nazi Party now the
vitriol from both the hard left and the
media and yeah there's some overlap
there is spewed even as president Trump
has attempted bipartisan outreach on
issues such as immigration reform
the Democrats rejected it last February
now others might have responded to the
political stonewalling by the Democrats
with a to hell with the whole bipartisan
thing but not Trump he's undeterred
trying to find common ground announcing
his support last week of an issue that
Democrats once heartily clamored for I'm
talking about criminal justice reform
Americans from across the political
spectrum can unite around prison reform
legislation that will reduce crime while
giving our fellow citizens a chance at
redemption so if something happens and
they make a mistake they get a second
chance at life
this got about as much coverage as his
visit to California this weekend in
other words not that much
not one Senate Democrat attended the
White House announcement which I found
to be a disgrace this political sleight
was not lost by the way on senator Cory
Booker's home paper today The
star-ledger wrote the following Booker
who's made a huge issue about justice
reform should have gone to the White
House and showed bipartisanship
Democrats can engage with the White
House and show independence at the same
time apparently not
the left's new strategy is to completely
deny the Trump has accomplished anything
positive and to deny him any cooperation
even on issues were they agree now how
sick is that only a few fair-minded
liberals like CNN's Van Jones who worked
with the White House including Jared
Kushner on this bill actually celebrated
the accomplishment the president Trump
said listen if this is going to make
streets safer if it's going to give
people a fair chance
if these being some of these forgotten
men and women some of them are in
Appalachia as well let's do something
and so listen I think you got to give
him some credit when I'll give him a
salute and an applause and for that
statement of support Jones was last
serrated professor Krystal Murray
Fleming tweeted give the white
supremacist misogynist his due Van Jones
says others were equally unhinged
Michael Harriet at the root saying no
Van Jones I do not have to give the
racist in chief his due so much for
common cause now by the way for all you
looking like to the Obama presidency
through these rose-colored glasses today
this is what the country felt about the
state of America
six years into Obama's presidency fifty
five percent said Obama had done more to
divide than unite the country well now
this is something the president at the
time said he had to admit when he gave
his final State of the Union address
it's one of the few regrets of my
presidency that the rancor and suspicion
between the parties has gotten worse
instead of better well are things today
worse maybe and both folks from both
parties they can do better including the
president quoting me every all of us I
guess and we should celebrate though the
president because he's trying to reach
across the aisle criminal justice reform
is just one of the examples and just
because haters on the left are gonna
ridicule him or belittle the president's
efforts is no reason for the president
to back off his trip to California
prison reform his work to lift the
standard of living of minority
communities it's all positive signs
there are those who will work overtime
to deflect and demean any efforts by
this president to broaden his appeal and
most importantly to broaden the appeal
of his policies that again are working I
say let the critics do what the critics
are gonna do this will make them look
petty and just pure partisan Reagan
appealed to women and minorities by
smiling through the storm always keeping
the focus on the lives of everyday
Americans Trump calls them the Forgotten
people their families their jobs their
neighborhoods their faith by taking the
focus off himself and keep it keeping it
on the horizon a possibility the
resident will unmask the real dividers
and give voters more of what they're
hungry for unity through strength and
that's the angle